knock and talk they ride together
they're willing to die together they're
bad boys for life and they're coming for
you built on the foundation of a
Rocksteady relationship between two
longtime friends the high powered action
film is heading to theaters soon here's
everything you need to know before you
go Will Smith and Martin Lawrence are
back to reprise their roles as Mike
Lowrey and Marcus Burnett two police
detectives in Miami Florida they began
their relationship as wary partners and
bad boys and deepen their brotherly
friendship and bad boys - the first bad
boys film was directed by Michael Bay
and focused on police partners Mike and
Marcus narcotics officers with
strikingly different personal styles
Mike is a fashionable and fancy-free
single fellow while Marcus is a more
conservative family man after a ton of
heroin is stolen from police
headquarters they are charged with
recovering it from my French drug lord
but in order to do so they end up
switching identities to persuade a
reluctant witness played by Te'o Leone
to help them Mike and Marcus really do
not get along but the hilarious
chemistry between Smith and Lawrence
combined with BAE's sense of kinetic
action made the film into a massive hit
their dynamic is just hysterical they
can do something that seems so serious
and say something that just has you
packing up and arriving eight years
later the sequel finds Mike and Marcus
assigned to lead a task force to capture
a Cuban drug lord and a halt to a war
that's broken out in the drug underworld
the two cops bigger constantly somebody
shot you
and who beat you me I shot you yeah it's
like you hit the meat it ain't no wet
noodle and tension between them is
heightened when it's revealed that Mike
has been dating Marcus's sister SID
played by Gabrielle Union Marcus
continues to want to spend more time
with his family but that all gets put on
the back burner by the case which
becomes even more outlandish under the
direction of Michael Bay so where
exactly does this story pick up and bad
boys for life sometimes you try to do it
you try to do a movie after 23 years
saying you're gonna do them a hit you
[Laughter]
well Marcus is now ready to settle down
and retire from the police force forcing
Mike to team up with a new younger team
of officers to investigate a powerful
drug dealer but things do not go as
planned leaving Mike to beg Marcus to
reconsider and return to his side for
one last time one last time proving that
they are truly bad boys for life the two
longtime friends aim to bring down the
powerful drug dealer Armando Armas who
is played by Jacob Scipio Armando who is
the head of the drug cartel is a
cold-blooded killer who is motivated by
revenge the duo has seen attempting to
take him down through a hail of bullets
fire explosions and multiple speeding
vehicles the new film also promises to
deliver a deeper insight into the loyal
friendship between Mike and Marcus and
while the third installment will be
jam-packed with just as many clever and
self-aware jokes as before we fully
anticipate that the action will also be
turned up no Joe Pantoliano returns from
the first two films as supervising
officer captain Howard me and joining
franchise for the first time is Vanessa
Hudgens Alexander Ludwig and Charles
Melton the trio will be a part of a
highly specialized police unit who
clashed with Lawrence and Smith would
sit on it
what's she gonna do when we come No the
cast will also include performances by
Paulo Nunez kate del Castillo
oh no somos le link on the bad boys for
life Katie I suppose we are good your
sons will never know sighs think gravely
Frankie's yacon will be nothing whoa
whoa it's gonna be in the prompter all
you have to do is just read it gracias
Raina's Lena you have to use your
epiglottis more like no you can't use
your epiglottis on TV come on Dora naina
why are you putting you don't stick your
neck out you just say the line listen
Nicky Jam and even DJ Khaled while bad
boys and bad boys too were directed by
Michael Bay this third installment will
be directed by ideal lrb and the law of
Allah best known for their work on the
crime drama black and epic series
snowfall working with babies is like a
dream come true and they're also very
professional and you know when you put
them together Martin and will is just
you know this chemistry it's magic so
now you know and now you can go see bad
boys for life in theaters January 17
[Music]